Did Teri Garr really boldly go off the set to
protest Star Trek's sexist wardrobe choices?
As groovy as Star Trek: The Original Series
is, the 1960s sci-fi television series hasn't
always aged well in the years since its original
run. Blatant sexism, both on and off the screen,
was unfortunately par for the course at the time,
something that one Star Trek alum notably called
out. Appearing in just one episode, actor Teri
Garr had an experience so uncomfortable
that she may have walked off the set.
Garr plays Roberta Lincoln in the episode
"Assignment: Earth," secretary to Gary Seven,
whose mission is to stop humanity from destroying
itself. The stakes are undoubtedly high, but you
wouldn't know it considering the wardrobe note
that showrunner Gene Roddenberry gave Garr. For
the episode, Garr was already wearing a criminally
short skirt, but Roddenberry insisted that it be
shortened by another two inches. According to The
Impossible Has Happened: The Life and Work of Gene
Roddenberry, author Lance Parkin recounted that
the actor was so insulted that she walked off set.
But someone who was there at the time has a
different story. In a conversation captured
in Inside Star Trek: The Real Story, assistant
director Robert Justman, recalls the incident.
"Teri understood the machinations
of show business [...] so she didn't
object when just before her first scene
on stage, Gene went to work on her costume
again. [...] Teri looked embarrassed when
she was called to set for her first shot."
Whether or not she stormed off set, Garr's
negative experience with Star Trek was a
turning point. Although she finished her work on
the episode, she washed her hands of anything to
do with the franchise in the future. Even
years later, in an interview with Starlog,
Garr slammed the Star Trek universe and its
fans, and even maligned sci-fi as a genre.
"We're really something. Star Trek
fans believe that. And so do I."
Teri Garr's sexist experience at the hands
of Gene Roddenberry speaks to the troubled
legacy of the show and its creator.
While elements of the original entry
in the Star Trek canon have been praised
for being progressive, the series and its
writers have also been criticized for portraying
female characters through a misogynistic lens.
There are plenty of examples. In Season 2's "The
Changeling," a robot analyzes the brain of Uhura,
only to label her as defective and
nonsensical because she's a woman.
In the Season 3 episode "Turnabout Intruder,"
Captain Kirk is possessed by his ex-girlfriend,
only for the team to realize this fact
due to how emotionally volatile he acts.
"You will obey my orders! Or you
will be charged with mutiny!"
Beyond Garr, other people involved with various
chapters of the Star Trek franchise over the years
have commented on its controversial history,
and Roddenberry himself. Actor Kate Mulgrew,
who starred as Captain Kathryn
Janeway in Star Trek: Voyager,
remarked in a 2019 interview with the Radio Times
that despite Roddenberry's visionary status,
he and his original creation were
still stuck with outdated values.
"It was extremely misogynist. That's what it
was for years and [Next Generation] followed
that to a certain extent. Roddenberry himself was
that way. We are simply going to have to change
this sensibility, this ideology, and we are, but
it's like moving granite. It takes a long time."
Mulgrew's Voyager, despite being the
first series led by a female captain,
also took a few giant steps backwards after the
first few seasons. When Jeri Ryan landed the
role as the de-assimilated Borg Seven of Nine, she
had more to handle than just on-set tension with
Kate Mulgrew. Her famous corset on the show was a
source of discomfort, especially when she needed
time to herself. The costume was so elaborate that
she needed help anytime she needed the bathroom.
Ryan recalled during a 2020 Voyager reunion,
"If I had to go, it was on the radio,
'Jeri's going. 10-1. That's 20.' Because,
you know, I had to have somebody dress me and
undress me. [...] It was a 20-minute thing to
get me undressed, go to the bathroom, get
dressed, go back to set. It was a thing."
Ryan became so self-conscious that
she even tried limiting food and
liquids just so she wouldn't hold up
production. The actor's skin-tight suit
represented an objectification that
Star Trek had been moving away from,
and was a big reason why Ryan and Mulgrew
notoriously didn't see eye to eye. Thankfully,
in her appearance in Star Trek: Picard, Ryan
seemed to have a much more comfortable outfit.